an automaton day and onion soup a
champion I like her anger times because
there's so much like us picolinate DNA
is practically the same as ours and
their behavior is similar to for
instance the young ones vie for
attention they want to cuddle their
defiance they can also get angry they're
like us and that fascinates me if the
mom would say that about a Batman yeah
me too - yeah Dora has waited the entire
morning for this moment to get out of
her cage and into the forest she's five
years old and an orphan she was kept
illegally as a house pet for most of her
life
around a year ago she was taken away
from her owner now her trainers take her
into the forest every day for climbing
practice
at this jungle school Dora learns the
skills she'll need to survive in the
wild today Pater Plataea from the
frankfurt zoological society has come
along to see how dora is progressing at
the reintroduction station we've seen
orangutans who've been kept caged up
venture out onto branches as thin as the
bars of their cages their cages were
stable and secure so at first they climb
up small trees or hold onto tiny
branches and often come crashing down
the next lesson is how to build a nest
around new tanks living in the wilds
build a new one each night as protection
against parasites but Dora still prefers
to use the ready-made nest meanwhile
back at the camp
Fatima and her colleagues are preparing
a meal fit for an orangutan fruit
wrapped in banana leaves and tied up
with string
Dora and her fellow orangutangs need to
learn that getting food requires some
effort cages they get fruit from the
forest once a day it's not as attractive
as cultivated fruit the wild varieties
aren't as sweet or as juicy they're
relatively dry and hard in comparison
but we have to get them to eat it anyway
how to find food is one of the most
important lessons the orangutangs must
learn here Dora is learning to suck
termites out of their nest high in
protein the insects can prove a vital
energy source during lean times her
trainers also demonstrate how to get the
goodness out of a stem of rattan palm
Ratan has an alternative at times when
there's no fruit in the forest during
the dry season they usually eat termites
Ratan and lee.toma consume the lights
lengua bukit tigapuluh is one of
Sumatra's largest remaining rainforests
it provides food and a home to countless
animal species protecting this unique
environment has become pedro Partiers
life's work of the six thousand
orangutans living in the wild here in
Sumatra only 1,600 live in protected
areas the future will depend on how well
these sanctuaries are protected that
will prove decisive in determining
whether the species is still around in
the next millennium or whether it will
dire need a reintroduction station there
are signs of logging and slash-and-burn
land clearing palm oil plantations in
particular keep encroaching on woodland
some two-thirds of Sumatra's rainforest
has vanished over the last 50 years
taking the orangutan habitat along with
it so preserving the rain forest is now
conservationists top priority back at
the jungle camp a new orangutan has
arrived around 10:00 come here for
training each year we have a new
orangutan his name is Blanco and he was
kept illegally he's just five years old
and needs training so that eventually he
can survive on his own in the forest but
I have a CDL I'm broken Dory's days of
living in a cage are over her trainers
have decided that she's ready to be
released into the jungle animal rights
activists have reintroduced around 160
orangutangs into the wild even if Dora
seems a little hesitant she's going to
join her fellow primates in the forest
and help strengthen their population
her release will take place deep in the
forest her trainers keep going until
they find the perfect location here
there's a source of water close by and
they leave a bit of food handy
it went well she's off to a good start
she climbed to the treetops and stayed
in the forest canopy it's like when your
kids finish high school
you're glad but when they leave home to
go to college that's hard for parents
but it's what's supposed to happen and
that's what counts
the conservationists will keep an eye on
Dora for a little while yet until
they're sure she's putting into practice
what she's learned at the jungle school
only then will she be able to thrive and
breed in the wild